[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم موعدنا الاسبوعي
مع الشان الاسرائيلي وماذا يقول الاعلام
الاسرائيلي وصديقنا الدكتور احمد فؤاد
انور مساء الخير معال الدكتور اهلا صديق
العزيز سيد بيه الله يخليك ويحفظك عندي
مجموعه كثيره من الاسئله ولكن اسمح لي
السؤال الاول احنا بنسجل الحلقه دي قبيل
سويعات قليله من انتهاء الهدنه الاولى
التي قد تمدد وقد لا تمدد قبل ما اسال
حضرتك عن احتمالات التمديد ام الحرب من
استفاد في رايك ومن خسر من هذه الهدنه
بايجاز شديد يعني اي حرب بقى جمال الاطراف
خسره لكن في هذه الحاله واضح جدا الجانب
الاسرائيلي هو الخاسر الاكبر او الاكثر
خساره بمعنى ان كان من المتصور ان اسرائيل
تعرضت للطم يوم سبعه وانها تستعيد الردع
وتحقق اهداف وانجازات في قطاع غزه وسقف
التوقعات كان بيتحدث عن تغيير خريطه الشرخ
الاوسط وليس فقط انجاز محدود داخل القطاع
فوجد نفسه حاليا ان في حوالي 120 دوله
تعترض على الروايه الاسرائيليه وجد ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي غير قادر في 50 يوم
ضد فصيل محاصر من 17 سنه ان حقق انجازات
يمكن الترويج ليها او يمكن الاشاره ليها
فهذا امر الامر الثاني انت بتقول ان حماس
دي زي داعش انت بتتفاوت وسيط داعش اللي
انت بتقول عليها داعش يعني تتصرف بانسانيه
المحتجزين بتوعك قالوا كده انت دلوقتي في
مجموعه داخل الجيش الاسرائيلي ا قائد سريه
والنائب بتاعه لم ينسحبوا في مع معركه ولم
ينسحبوا من قطاع غزه دول خرجوا على بيوتهم
السريه دي لم تعد الى الخدمه بمعنى ان
الجانب الاسرائيلي اعترف بعد ان صرحت حماس
بان في موقعه وان القوات انسحبت بان
الواقعه صحيحه وان تم التحقيق وان تم
اقاله الضابط والنائب الخاص به وان تم
استقدام قوات مكان القوات الرافض فده تمرد
يعني مش موضوع ان انا ما قدرتش ما
صمدت استدعيت الطيران الطيران ما جاش فده
مؤشر خطير الاخطر ان الرقابه العسكريه
تسمح بذلك استاذن حضرتك قبل ما ما نستانف
الاجابه هل ممكن توضح لنا بتبسيط روايه
انسحاب سريه هي سريه ولا سريتين سريه
بلوجاب العبري القائد والنائب تم اقالتهم
لانهم كانوا في شمال قطاع غزه المعارك
هناك والاعلان تم النهارده يعني بنتكلم
على تعتيم لمده ايام على الراي العام
الاسرائيلي الجانب الفلسطيني المقاوم اعلن
الجانب الاسرائيلي الجانب الفلسطيني من
اسبوع قال ان في سريه انسحبت ا في سريه
انسحبت امام نيراننا اه الجانب الاسرائيلي
النهارده اعترف وتطوع بان الموضوع اخطر من
كده الموضوع النهارده
28 ا نوفمبر نوفمبر فبنت ان في مؤشر على
ان انا اللي هاممني ان الجانب الرقابي سمح
بالنش فده بيمه الراي العام الاسرائيلي
بان يا جماعه الامور اختلفت وان انسوا بقى
الوعود القديمه احنا بنحاول نوقف الناس
اللي بترجع لبيوتها دي اللي هو عمليه
التمرد والانسحاب اه بالضبط ف ماحدش نجر
في اسرائيل انا عارف ان ده ممكن يكون صعب
اسباب هروب هذه السريه لا هو انا بحكي
لحضرتك اللي ما سمح بنشره ان هو القائد
والنائب وان العناصر
جوه لم تعد تم استعاده عنهم باخرين وان هم
يعني بيقولوا انتب بتعاقبوهم انتم ما
جيتوش تنقذنا يعني انا لما انسحبت وخرجت
يعني نوع من الاحتجاج والتمرد الشامل
وبيحاولوا دلوقتي تصدقهم يعني ان ما يبقاش
في عقوبات اكت الجيش الاسرائيلي
بشان التمرد لا يزيد يعني بالضبط ده الامر
غير مسبوق على اكثر من مستوى الامر الثاني
ان في اسرائيل رقابه عسكريه فانا لما
الاقي الرقابه العسكريه بتعلن عكس ما تروج
اسرائيل طوال الوقت اثناء الحروب بان في
بطولات وان في صمود بتعلن وتقر بان في
هروب ليس من معركه لكن من قطاع بل تمرد
على الخدمه اثناء الحرب وما فيش عقاب قوي
ل للذين شاركوا في الانسحاب والهروب فده
مؤشر على تمهيد الراي العام الى تراجع
كبير الى هزيمه ما الى نقوص عن الوعود
التي تم قطعها بانه ليس في الامكان تحقيق
ما يمكن ان نكون قد وعدنا به في البدايه
فعلى الجمعيه ان يتهيا لحاله جديده على
التعامل مع الواقع الحالي في ظل هذه
القماشه هذه المجموعه التي تنسحب وتفر هي
وجنود اللي انت قلته ده وده كلام جيد جدا
مؤشرات على انه اسرائيل لم تستطع ان تحقق
انجازا يذكر على الارض بعد مرور اكثر من
50 يوم لكن انا سؤالي ايوه اضطروا الى عقد
هدنه ايوه واحد اسباب قبولهم
بالهدنيا الاسرى او المحتجزين او الره كما
سميهم زي ما انت عاوز فلجا الى الهدنه
خلال اربع ايام هدنه الاولى ايو هل من
استفد ومن تضرر في تقديرك او الصحف
الاسرائيليه بتقول ايه بكل تاكيد اسرائيل
تضررت لانها تكمم افواه من تم اطلاق سراحه
من الجانب الاسرائيلي بمعنى ان كان في في
البدايه يعني بادره حسنيه من المقاومه
مسنه تم الافراج عنها تحدثت في المستشفى
عن ان المعامله طيبه وان ان كان في رعايه
طبيه وكان في مسعف وكان في طبيب وما الى
ذلك فتم معاقبه مدير المستشفى الذي سمح
بعقد المؤتمر الصحفي من الاساس ولم تتكرر
هذه لان هي تحدثت بشكل ايجابي ايجابي فده
جزء الجزء الثاني ان اسرائيل جيش الاحتلال
بيمنع ايام الهدنه دخول الصحفيين الى قطاع
غزه بدون مرافقته ففي هذا برده مصادره على
الروايه الاخرى او الروايه الحياديه ما
انا ممكن اروح اشوف الشفا واراجع بقى
موضوع النفق اللي انتوا قلتوا عليه هل هو
خارج الشفا بقد ايه وانما هم يقولوا تكون
مرافقين ليك فده ايضا يدل على ضعف الروايا
الاسرائيليه الجانب الاخر ان حماس اسهمها
بتطلع انا دلوقتي من الاول واخداهم مش
عشان احبسهم 20 سنه انا واخداهم وبقول
عايزه اعمل صفقه تبادل اسرى فكبرت الطرف
الاخر على الانصياع لرؤيتي ورغبتي بعد 50
يوم من المحاولات
فده امر يرفع منسوب شعبيه حماس بكل تاكيد
يعني اذا كنا بنتكلم على ان التسليم كمان
تم في شمال غزه احنا دلوقتي بنقول ان
دخلنا قطاع غزه قسمناه اثنين ان الشمال
معانا وسيطرنا عليه بعد اه بعد ما دكنا
وان خلاص حماس هربت على الجنوب وان الشمال
خيالي وادي الناس هي نازحه شايفين الصور
اتضح ان في نصف مليون في شمال قطاع غزه
لسه موجودين
المخيمات مكتظه ما حدش خرج الاسواق في
المخيمات شغاله ان قط ان مدينه غزه الساحه
الرئيسيه فيها عربيات مكشوفه لحماس في ناس
واقفه بانضباط في تصوير من الجو ان في
اريحيه في تسليم الدفعه الثالثه الى
الصليب الاحمر فده يدل لا ان احنا الجانب
الاسرائيلي لم يسيطر على شمال غزه بالكامل
بالعكس
في سيطره ايضا
للقوات المقاومه الكتايب وادائها منضبط لا
تحيه للكتاب تحيه للمقاومه تحيه للاداء
يعني انا بتكلم ان في خطاب اعلامي جيد مع
العالم اللي بيقول انتم ارهابيين طب ما
امريكا بتقول على منظمه تحرير ارهابيين
ايه البديل يعني انت انت دلوقتي بتقول لي
الطرف ده وحش اجيب لك مين صحيح عندك ده
اعترفوا بدوله اسرائيل هو بيقول على حماس
ارهابيه منظمه بيقول على منظمه التحرير
اللي هي تعتبر المنظمه الحاكمه يعني امص
تعمل تنسيق امني مع الجانب الاسرائيلي
تعرف طب اجيب لك مين في الصحف الاسرائيليه
حد بيقول انه حماس استفادت من الهدنه سواء
سياسيا او عسكريا لا هو طبعا يعني ما
بيوصلو للدرجه دي انما بيقولوا احنا ما ن
دورش على نصر خلاص صور نصر لن تحدث في
المستقبل مش بنتكلم على ان ممكن دلوقتي
لسه ما وصلناش نقطه يقولوا في المستقبل
خلاص احنا خسرنا هذه الحرب قالوا كده بشكل
صريح يعني فالجزء الثانيه اللي برض اشير
اليها ان امبارح اول امبارح اول اول
امبارح كانوا بيقولوا على الاطفال
الفلسطينيين اللي ما كانش حد بيتكلم عنهم
في العالم وسايبين النساء في السجون
الاسرائيليه اه والنساء الفلسطينيات اللي
برضو في السجون وما حدش بيتكلم عنهم سجون
اسرائيل بيقولوا عليهم ارهابيين مخربين طب
وبعد ما حكمت عليهم النهارده اجبرت انا
كاسرائيل ان انا اخرجهم وما ظهر الاحتفال
و يعني انا دلوقتي بيقولوا يعني ان ده
لطمه كبيره جدا ان دي كانت هتفجر فينا
عربيه ناسفه وبتاع وان الطفل دوت كان معاه
مولوتوف ده مش طفل ولا حاجه ده مخرب طب
انا تاني يوم عملت العكس افرجت عنه ف يعني
اذا كنت انت بتقول ان انت بتثق في قضائك
وبتعتبر ان من حبستهم دول ارهابيين يبقى
انت كده اجبرت اجبارا على ايوه
ا انا عندي ملحوظه انا انا انا شعرت يعني
انه يعني حماس وكتائب القسام استفادت في
مساله تبادل الاسرى باكثر من الفائده
العاديه المتوقعه في ان انا فرضت وجهه
نظري ان انا استعدت المحررين ولكن
استغلتها لارسال رساله يعني انه انا لسنا
داعش نحن لسنا وحوشا ام نحن لسنا من
صورتهم في الاعلام باننا نغتصب ونقتل
اطفال وصوره الجنود اللي هم يبدو ان هم
بيختارهم بعنايه كلهم اجسام ما شاء الله
كده ولكن ماسك بنت والبنت بتقول له حتى في
حد عامل كاريكاتير لطيف كده تعالوا اخطفو
تاني
ايو فدوا رساله مؤثره يعني انت قلت لي انه
اسرائيل ابتدت تقلق من الرساله ديت وبدات
تحاصرها صحيح هي طبعا مش تعرف تحاصرها في
الخارج بس على الاقل بتحاول تحاصرها في
الداخل كيف تحاول اسرائيل التعامل مع هذه
الرسائل الايجابيه عن صوره حماس وكتاب
القسام يعني هي طبعا منعت المؤتمرات
الصحفيه وفي نفس الوقت مؤتمرات الصحفيه
لمين للمحتجزين الذين تم تحريرهم والافراج
عنهم فده امر طبعا مهم الحاجه الثانيه ان
في مخصصات ليهم دعم نفسي دعم مالي لمره
واحده اول مره مبلغ كبير بعد كده دعم شهري
فانا اذا كنت هالف التعليمات وابتدي اقول
لا حماس فعلا كان بتعملنا كويس المقاومه
كذا هيتم منع
فورا المخصصات دي فدي من ضمن سياسه العصا
والجزره طبعا اول حاجه ان هم خدوهم حققوا
معاهم عشان يفهموا يعني الوجبات اه كانوا
بيجيبوا لنا بيتزا كتير طب بالنسبه لدورات
المياه كنا بالدور طب ايه مش ما فيش
معلومات يعني ايه يمكن ان التعويل عليها
ان مخزن السلاح كان على اي الشمال مثلا
ولا مافيش حاجه اطفال اصلا ونساء وحماس
تتحسب منذ البدايه وكانوا بينقلوا لنا
كتير كانوا بينقلوا لنا من مكان لمكان طب
انا استفدت ايه يعني يعني ما فيش معلومه
يمكن هو طبعا ممكن نظريا ان هو يقول طب
انا دلوقتي اخدت 50 احاول اطلع جزء من ال
50 الثانيين اللي اتفقنا عليهم من
المدنيين بالقوه باعتماد
المعلومات والصور طبعا في اار صناعيه
بتصور وشوفنا الميكروباس طلع والثلاث
عربيات خاصه ب القسام طلعت في ساحه في
مدينه غزه فممكن تحليل هذه الصور يؤدي الى
بيسموه ايه يعني ميح
يط انما طبعا هتبقى مغامره كبيره جدا لان
تاريخهم في تحرير الرهائن سيء جدا محاولات
في واحد اسمه نحشون فاكسمان ده جندي فتم
اختطافه وتم الترويج ان هو في غزه طلع ان
هو في الضفه فرحهم بالقوات الخاصه فبدل ما
يحرر الجندي مات وفي ضابط قوات خاصه من
المهاجمين مات و سبعه اص سنه كام يا دكتور
ده في التسعينات بدايه التسعينات فده كان
من العمليات الصادمه طب هم ازاي اتقتل
الجندي اذا كانوا هم هاجموا غزه والجندي
موجود في الضفه لا هم ما هاجمو غزه هو
الشريط الفيديو اللي بيقول ان هو عايش طلع
من من غزه لل تضليل فقعدوا يستهلكوا وقت
فين في غزه فين في غزه لغايه ما تاكدوا من
التضليل ده تم وان الجندي في في مكان
فقتلوا اسرهم يعني قتلوا اسرهم وضابط كمان
الحادثه دي اتكررت مع حافله كان في حافله
اختطفها هواه فلسطينيين مش محترفين خالص
يعني فبدل ما يخش او يتفاوض دخل وقتل من
القسر بتوعه الا برصاص اسرائيلي فهم حتى
عنتيبي هم بيقدموها نموذج طيب لا هي عملاه
فش ممكن تفكر الناس عن باختصار يعني اه دي
كانت طائره رحله طيران ل شركه فرنسيه
وراحت اوغندا هبطت وكان في حديث عن صفقه
تبادل اسرى فبدل ما يعملوا الصفقه قالوا
يلا نحرر الاسر
ونقح الطائره الطه دي اختطفت مش كده برض
اختطفت وهبطت في مطار مدني في اوغندا اه
وكان في الخ خطه ان هننزل بعربيه مرسيدس
مشابهه لعربيه الرئيس الاوغندي وهنخس
عليهم ان الرئيس احتفا الرئيس جاي يتفاوض
بنفسه فيفتحون لنا فان نحرر فمات فيها اخو
اخو نتنياهو نتنياهو وهو دلوقتي حاليا
بيقولوا صفقه وازمه رهائن اتت بنتنياهو
لانه تاجر بالموضوع ده وان شاء الله ازمه
رئن الحاليه تخلصنا منه دي حلوه دي هو
فعلا ل من لا يعرف يعني هو بدايه نتنياهو
دخول السياسه كان من مقتل اخوه ارجو ان
انت تصححي يعني في عنتيبي هو طفل فا اخوه
ده لما قتل اثناء محاوله تحرير
الاسرائيليين اللي اخت اختطفتهم منظمه
التحرير فلسطينيه مش كده غالبا حس في او
قوه فلسطينيه انا لا اذكر تحديدا يعني سنه
74 وهبطوا بها في عنتيبي عنتيبي في اوغندا
اوغندا في اوغندا فحصل بعد مقتل اخوه ضمن
الاسرائيليين اللي قتلوا اثناء عمليه
التحرير ان بدا هو يدخل عالم السياسه
معهد لضد مكافحه الارهاب مكافحه الارهاب
وذكرى اخويا وهكذا وبقى نائب وزير في مكتب
رئيس الوزراء شمير شمير اول واحد قال
البحر هيفضل بحر والعرب هيفضلوا عرب
ونتنياهو هيفضل نتنياهو مش نافع والله اه
طبعا استاذه هو بعد ما شاف الاداء قلا اي
حد غير نتنياهو يمسك مش هو بس يعني كتير
قالوا كده عايز اسالك على موضوع يعني انا
بالنسبه لي شويه اثار علامات استفهام
بالنسبه لي بس يبدو ان اللي بيتابع الشان
بشكل اكثر دقه اقل اندهاشا مني الرئيس
المصري من عده ايام تحدث عن تصوراته للحل
او جزء من تصوراته للحل واشار الى قيام
دوله فلسطينيه منزوعه السلاح في حدود
متابعتي انا دي اول مره
سياسي مصري او عربي او حتى فلسطيني يتحدث
علنا عن دوله فلسطينيه منزوعه السلاح كلنا
فاهمين ان ده هيتم في النهايه بس ماحدش
بيسرح بده
علنا لما سالت بعض الاصدقاء زي حضرتك كده
قالوا لي طب ما اه يعني ما هو ده معروف
وانه السلطه تعلم ذلك و يعني تبارك ذلك
صحيح او يعني توافق على ذلك مش تبارك ذلك
ايه القصه يعني ايه ما هو القصه ان احنا
حاليا كل
الجهود تهدف الى حكم ذاتي ان في حكم ذاتي
فلسطيني على الاراضي الفلسطينيه المنطقه
اي وبي وسي في الضفه تقريبا زائد غزه زائد
غزه وان يكون في ممر امن بين الاثنين بين
ضفه وغزه سواء بقى نفق سواء كبري مسار
تكون عليه سياده ما تكونش عليه سياده
وطبعا القدس الشرقيه هو الفكره زي فكره
ا اسرائيل الاساسيه ان انا ليه اقدم حاجه
من الاساس انا ليه اعمل حكم ذاتي و وانا
كده يعني انا ما هزمت انا مش ما تمش
ترقيعي فاحنا بنتكلم على خطوه للامام ولا
خطوه للخلف احنا مش عارفين نثبت الحكم
الذاتي احنا دلوقتي احنا العرب انا بتكلم
العرب يعني فكره انت عشان بس يبقى اللي مش
متابع القصه يبقى فاهم انت بتقول انه انه
السلطه الفلسطينيه وافقت على د دوله على
على على على مدن غزه زائد الضفه الغربيه
بينهما فاصل بينهما يعني ممر امن مر ام
وتنازلت عن فكره ان هي تمتلك سلاح لان هذا
هو افضل خيار لسه ما وصلناش ما انا اخد
الخطه يعني هي الفكره ايه خذ ثم طالب فهو
الفكره ايه الناس عندها حساسيه كده يقول
لك وانت بتقول القدس الشرقيه بس ليه ما هي
القدس الشرقيه هي التي تحدثت عنها
القرارات الامميه ولما اوصل لها نبقى
نتكلم على القدس الغربيه اه يعني هي فكره
العصافير اللي على الشجره يعني انت دلوقتي
دلوقتي عمال تعد العصافير اللي على الشجره
انت خد اثنين وحاول بقى تزودهم يب ثلاثه
انما انا ما عنديش في ايدي اي حاجه دلوقتي
غير سلطه فلسطينيه محاصره يمكن لسكري من
جيش الاحتلال ان يوقف اي وزير يوقف الرئيس
الوزراء اصلا سبق ان قتلوا عرفات فانا رد
فعل الاسرائيلي هو اللي يهمني كمتخصص
هسالك عليه بس الاول نقول كده معنى كده
انه معروف انه السلطه موافقه انه اذا
تيبقى انجاز بالنسبه لها تتمنى طبعا لو ان
يكون في حكم ذاتي على اراضي الضفه الغربيه
زائد غزه بيبقى مر امن ايوه ثم تسعى
لتطوير الحكم الذاتي ده يبقى ايه اكتر
شويه من حكم ذاتي اه هو ثم اه هو احنا
بنتكلم على ايه يعني المرحله الحاليه
وبرده يبقى ربنا فرج من وسع ان هو اكتر من
حكم ذاتي واقل من دوله اه ليه هو ده
المجتمع الدولي اللي متاح امام
التوافقات الدوليه والتجاذبات فهو في فكره
كده برض معلش زي دوله مع كامل التقدير
والاحترام وانا الجيش اللبناني على راسي
يعني بس الجيش اللبناني ما عندوش قوات
جويه قويه ما عندوش دفاع جوي قوي مش عشان
هو مش قادر يستلف ويشتري علشان هو ده
المسكوت عنه واتفاقات غير مكتوبه بان
المجال الجوي اللبناني يبقى مستباح من
اسرائيل فاسرائيل لما بتعمل حسابات ان
الجبهه اللبنانيه تتفتح تتكلم على حزب
الله ما بتقولش حزب الله واحتمال برض
الجيش اللبناني يتعاطف او ان هو يساند
لانه مش في الحسابات لان الاتفاق كده انما
تحت الارض حزب الله موجود هو خارج متمرد
عن الاتفاق انه انه احنا بنتكلم على سلطه
فلسطينيه بدون سلاح واقع الامر بتتكلم ان
لبنان تقريبا بدون سلاح اه ف ده دوله
مستقله انا دلوقتي انا عايز اوصل ابقى
دوله مستقله وان متناقش انما المتاح
دلوقتي جيش واحد من البحر للنهر موافق
موافق مش موافق مش موافق هو الجيش
الاحتلال جيش واحد اللي هو الجيش الاحتلال
اه فانا بتكلم ان انا دلوقتي بتعامل
بالشكل خليني بقى ويني الشطاره وبدل ما
انا في غزه كده
باخد المنتجات وعليها بالعبري لمصنع
كذا يعني نوصل لمرحله الاستقلال الاقتصادي
ونبقى نتكلم عن ان انا عندي جيش قوي ولا
مش قوي شرطه قويه ولا شرطه ضعيفه طب انا
عشان افرق ما بين الراي وما بين الحقائق
سؤالي بقطع النظر عن واجهه الراي السلطه
الفلسطينيه وفقا لمعلوماتك قبلت مع الجانب
الاسرائيلي انه تبقى دوله بدون سلاح مظبوط
هي تتمنى ذلك لانها في تقديري وتقديرها
خطووه كبيره للامام تتمنى و م ذلك انها
وافقت اه ما تتمنى يبقى اكتر من موافقه
طيب خلاص يبقى ربنا فرج من واسع طيب اثنين
ايوه بقطع النظر عن انه ا السلطه
الفلسطينيه وافقت وانت بتقول اكتر من
وافقت هي
تمنت وبقطع النظر ان انا لم اسمع ذلك علنا
ابدا من اي مسؤول فلسطيني او مسؤول عربي
ربما يكون تقصير مني في
المتابعه انما اللي يهمني في السؤال بقى
جاء زعيم دوله عربيه قال والسلطه
الفلسطينيه لم
تعترض هل اسرائيل بقى يعني ابتهجت مثلا
بالفكره وقالت والله كويس ان في تحسن ان
الناس ابتدوا يقبلوا بفكره دويله صغيره من
زوعه السلاح ولكن رد فعل اسرائيل ايه على
تصريحات الرئيس المصري وعدم رفض او تعليق
او انتقاد السلطه الفلسطينيه لتصريحات
الرئيس المصري لا طبعا بيقول ولا زمن ذلك
كان موجود في 88 وخلص انت ضيعت الفرصه
انتوا بتتكلموا على ايه اللي يكبرني يعني
هو ده التعليقات رافضه لم تتلقى في
اسرائيل هذه الفكره ولا الولايات المتحده
يعني المفترض وعشان كده بقول لحضرتك
السلطه الفلسطين فلسطينيه او المسؤولين
الفلسطينيين هيتمنوا ليه لان الجانب
الاسرائيلي يرى ان دي ضده ان هي دي مش
هتفيده هي الفكره عامله زي النقب يلا يا
جماعه رجعوا الناس دي النقب انا كاسرائيل
بقول ما فيش الا سياده امنيه ا في هذه
المنطقه الا لي انا هو بيقول
مثلا مصر عايزه تشتري اسلحه متقدمه غير
متاح لازم اسرائيل توافق لان التوازن
هيختلف كالقاهرة
[موسيقى]
شايف الاسرائيلي بيتجاهل الاثنين العوده
الى النقب ولو مؤقتا وان احنا نعمل دوله
من الاساس انا اصلا مواصفاتها ايه الدوله
دي دي مرحله اللي بنتكلم فيها ونتف لا
خلاص انا تجاوزت موقف الفلسطين انا بقول
انه ليه فلسط ليه الاسرائيل لم تبتهج لا
هي هجمت
على الاقتراح
وشوهت سخرت منه وده دول ان هم ممتعين ان
هم مش عاجبهم ب انا كنت متخيل يعني او اي
حد عاقل هيقول لو ده في مصلحه اسرائيل
هترج له هتدي يقول لك ايه انت خدت خطوه
انا هاخد خطوه نلتقي في النص بمعنى ايه
تكون منزوعه السلاح وكمان كذا مافيش كمان
كذا حتى يعني هو انا هقول ايه نفكر فيها
ما فيش اللام مافيش الكلام ده هو طب انا
عايز اعرف تصوري يعني انه ما انت عاوز ايه
اكتر بان هم يوافقوا على ما لا يمكن
الموافقه عليه يعني د ويله على جزء من
اراضيهم منزوعه السلاح يعني انا عندي خطه
العكس انا ختي ان انا الخطه بتاعتي
التطهير العرقي لاراضي ال 48 دلوقتي دخلت
على التطهير العرقي ل 67 انا ما فيه كويس
انا كصه وي اسرائيلي بعمل ايه بمشي
الناس من 67 اراضي اللي سيطرت عليها بعد
67 فانا ايه اللي رجعني انا ايه اللي
رجعني واعمل دوله واقول لهم بس بشروط كذا
وكذا وكذا وترتيبات امنيه او منزوعه
السلاح انا ايه اللي دخلني في الحكايه دي
ما انا تمام كده انا قربت خلاص اطلعهم في
سينا اه اطلعهم الى سينا انا قربت ارحلهم
للاردن هو
شعار بعض الاحزاب السياسيه والعصابات
السونيه اللي قبل 48 طرحى مجددا والدوله
البديله في الاردن والحاجات دي مطروح بقوه
فانا بعد ما خلاص حطيت رجلي وفاضل الرجل
الثانيه تقول لي رجع الرجل اللي طلعت ف دي
العقليه الصونيه اللي هي ايه بكمل على
اللي قبلي انا يسار او يمين بكمل على اللي
قبلي فاللي قبلي وصل لان في مستوطنات
كتيره في الضفه
فالظهور مستويه ان حماس ارهابيه وان
الولايات المتحده ات جرين لايت وان الناس
نزلوا من الشمال حسب الروايه الا لايت ان
احنا نضربهم وان احنا نحجر مدنيين وهنرد
الطرف كده ايه اسبوعين ونشوف انت تخلص
الموضوع في اسبوعين مذابح بقى مش مذابح
شفا مش شفا اندونيسي مش اندونيسي تصرف في
الاسبوعين دي وحاول انا ايه انا هعمل نفسي
مش واخد بالي فالولايات المتحده والاداره
الامريكيه بدات تراجع مواقفها بعد 50 يوم
بعد 50 يوم ولا لا معلش اليم بتاعك وقتك ا
على فكره دده وقت تاني قال لك طيب يعني مش
مشكله هدنا لغايه ما تاخد بس ال طيب
الاجابه يعني واضحه وصادمه طيب معالي
الدكتور عايز اسالك على حاجه عن فلسطين
وثم
او عرب 48 كما تحب ان تسميهم يعني اي عدد
عرب العرب او الفلسطينيين ممن يحملون جواز
السفر الاسرائيلي حوالي 2 مليون تمام
يمثلون حوالي 20% من اجمالي من يحمل جواز
السفر الاسرائيلي هم حوالي تسعه ونص او 10
مليون ص
صح حصل انه في اكثر من مره لما بيكون
الضغط عنيف على حماس او لما بتكون في
انتهاكات شديده جدا في القدس انه بيبقى في
انتفاضات داخل عرب 48 هذه المره رد فعل
الا 2ن مليون محدود ولا انا فاهم غلط لا
محدود جدا محدود جدا هل ممكن تقول لي كده
يعني الاسباب اللي انت رصدتها لعدم تجاوب
بشكل كافي من ال 2 مليون فلسطيني اللي
بيحملوا الجواز الاسرائيلي ولكن استاذنك
في نقاط سريعه يعني تمام هو في اكتوبر
2000 انفجر فلسطين 48
ردا على انتهاكات اريل شارون واقتحامه
للحرم حرم القدسي وكان زعيم المعارضه يعني
دلوقتي بقينا نشوف وزرا هم حكوميين هم
اللي بيقتح ده حاجه الحاجه الثانيه 21 ماي
21 كان في حارس الاسوار دي حمله ضد قطاع
غزه انفجر برض الداخل الفلسطيني اللي هو
في حدود ال 48 وكان في في ضد الشرطه و
وخاصه في المدن المشتركه اكتر حاجه السيد
بتمثل هاجس وكابوس للجانب الاسرائيلي ان
المدن المشتركه زي النصره زي حيفا زي يافا
وتله ابيب هما بلديه واحده تحصل فيها
الاشتباكات دي يعني واحد هيبص من الشباك
او في نفس العماره يروح بدل ما يقول له
صباح الخير اقتله اه فده اللي خوف سهل ان
يوصل للاخر يعني دي دي جزئيه في كانونات
كده مش ا دول مع بعضهم مثلا في كفر قاسم
بيحتاجوا يولعوا كويتش وبتاع و تضربوا في
الشرطه الشرطه تجي لهم انما مش عماره فيها
زي كفر صابه دي برض مشتركه فدي تمثل خطر
هم بيحطم ازاي هو الجانب الاسرائيلي مش
عايز يكرر السناريوهات ده فيشتغل بدري فال
على المستوى السياسي بدا يفتت ف بدا يطلع
منصور عباس بس اللي هو قائد لمجموعه بتسمى
القائمه الموحده رعم رعم دول طلعوا من
القائمه المشتركه كان في قائمه مشتركه لكل
اغلب الفلسطين ال 48 ينزلوا بها الكنيست
هم لو نزلوا في قايمه واحده هياخدوا خمس
الكنيست اللي هو حوالي 24 م اجمالي عدد
الكنيست 120 لو شفنا حصه ال 2 مليون هتبقى
حوالي 24 24 مقعد في الكنيس يبقى قوه
هائله ا بوا
مهم المتدينين اللي عاده يعني واخدين موقف
من الدوله السيه ا بيبقوا لسان ميزان وهم
ثمان مقاعد وتسع مقاعد يعني لما انا اوصل
25 وابقى القوه الثانيه ممكن اللي اللي
كود يبقى هو رقم واحد ب 30 وانا رقم اين
فممكن اتحال مع حزب العمل واليسار وميرت
ويسار الوسط واوقف هيبقى عندي للث معطل
فالمهم يعني ان هم فتتتو سياسيا اذا ف
يعني بايجاز شديد الى ان نتناولها لاحقا
مساله التفتيت فاصبحوا بدل من ان يكونوا
كتله واحده تعبر عن مصالح فلسطين 48
اصبحوا مجموعه من الكتل وتفتت وضعف عدد
مشاركتهم في الكنيست واحد ده عمل لهم
احباط سياسي يعني احباط عامل في العمل
العام مش عايز اشارك الجزء الثاني ان في
امنيا مخاطر على المجتمع الخاص بفلسطين ال
48 يتمثل في الجريمه المنظمه يعني السيد
في عصابات جريمه
منظمه تتسارع
داخل في على مناطق النفوذ
داخل المدن والاحياء الفلسطينيه ال 48
بالسيارات الناسفه عايز اقتل الاخ المنافس
بتاعي ف فخخ له عربيته في 2118 من فلسطين
ال 48 ماتوا برصاص فلسطيني 48 منذ بدايه
هذا العام فقط تقصد انه في جريمه منظمه
نشطه داخل تجمعات عرب 48 اه الشرطه
الاحتلال بتغد البصر عنه انا اعتقد كمان
بتساعدهم لان طبعا ما فيش حاجه اسمها افخخ
وعندي اسلحه وعندي نفوذ وشرطه الاحتلال
تقول له الله سيبهم يعني لا بالعكس هي لو
في واحد معاه بيسموها ايه قصافه بتقول لك
اه انت بتحاول تطعن جندي تعالى انما عشان
ده
طحن بين داخلي فلسطيني فلسطيني يعني اه
فده يقول لك تمام ده يصب في مصلحتي وانت
قلت لي قبل كده ان هم بيوا باسلحتهم من من
الجيش الاسرائيلي نفسه من جيش الاحتلال
بيتم الشرا وطبعا في بقى ان انا اضغط
على العنصر الثالث بقى الثالث بقى اضغط
على رؤساء البلديات انت في مصالح وفي
ميزانيات وكذا طب ما اركز على الميزانيات
وازود لك في مقابل ان انت تهدي الجماعه
بتوعك يعني وتقنع في حاجه تانيه اللي هي
وزاره معادات مكافحه معادات الساميه تم
تخصيص ميزانيه لهذه الوزاره وتوسيع نفوذها
انها تعلق لافتات ان احنا كلنا في مركب
واحده وان ما يصحش وان مصلحتنا ان احنا
نعدي الايام دي اذا انت بتقول ان عرب 48
او فلسطين و 48 استجابتهم ضعيفه هذه المره
لاربعه اسباب انت بتشير اليها واحد ان هو
تم تفتهم قبل مبكرا قبل عمليه غزه بكتير ا
من خلال قوى صغيره ضعيفه متنحه وابسط دليل
على ذلك ان بدل ما يكون وفقا للاعداد يكون
عدد نصيبهم في الكنيست 24 من 120 يعني
الخمس نصيبهم محدود جدا ومنقسم على انفسهم
هذا واحد اثنين بتقول
انه هم كمان
امنيا يعني مستنزف لانه في جريمه منظمه
ناشطه هناك وانت بتقول ان ين اذا لم
يساعدوهم فهم يغضون الطرف عن ذلك علشان
دايما يكونوا مستنزف امنيا ثلاثه بتقول
انه هؤلاء بيتم كمان اغرائهم ب او
مساومتهم رؤساء البلديات هناك نعطيك
ميزانيات نعطيك بعض الامتيازات في مقابل
ان تصمت عن اي تضامن مع فلسطين وال
الاراضي المحتله صح وبتقول ان في وزاره
وزاره اللي هي معادات الساميه بالاضافه
الاجهزه الامنيه في وزاره معنيه بانها
تهدي الجماعه دول جزيل الشكر معال الدكتور
شكرا يا سييد بي سعدايه باللقاء الله
يخليك ويسعدك وشكرا لحضراتكم ونلقاكم في
حلقات اخرى باذن الله